- Back in Sydney
(laughing)
- Where'd that bird go?
The
- The cow bird?
- Ya
(laughing)
(bird cawing)
- We are really in Australia now.
Today we are eating steak
starring Sydney.
Adam? You excited for a steak?
- What's going on here?
Whoa!
I don't think people can appreciate
how great this tree is.
- You certainly can because you're
stupid.
- Alright let's go get some steak.
Get your saliva rollin'.
Today on "Worth It" Australia edition.
We're gonna have three steaks at three
drastically different price points
to find out which steak in Australia
is the most worth it at its price.
Remember when we had steak before?
(classical music)
- Will it be surpassed today?
- I'm pretty sure this
is gonna be spectacular.
- Steaktacular?
- We are actually arriving right now
look at that.
- Hey, it's the ocean.
- All great restaurants are at the ocean.
Uh, well....
(laughing)
- Oh my God
- That's not true.
- Thank you
- Do you wanna be the host?
- Alrighty
- Take my mic, here take it.
- [Steven] Let's go
- I'll be camera guy for a day.
- Hi I'm Steven
(upbeat music)
- My name is Sebastien Lutaud and we
are at The Clovelly Hotel
close to the beach.
Today we're gonna be having a $16 steak
that we have on our steak
nights on Wednesday.
It's a piece of rump.
- Rump?
- Rump.
It's a part that's made to be a little
bit tougher on the back of the shoulder.
The rumps got a level of flavor
because its a muscle
that works a bit more.
The rump will come in portioned
salt, pepper, I don't do anything else
no spices or anything on it.
A bit of rush of bone marrow that's we've
been melted down just
a bit of extra flavor
that has rosemary and thyme in it.
Straight onto the top of the broiler
get a nice char on it, both sides
and straight into the
broiler in the middle
at about 700 degrees.
Char that for about 2 or 3 minutes
both sides then let it rest.
Steak today is gonna be coming with
green beans and mash.
- [Host] We're both pretty
new to Australian beers
is there one you would
recommend for us to have
with this steak?
- You know what there is a Bob Hawke one
Bob Hawke used to be an old Prime Minister
of Australia.
He's got a reputation for
scaling the fastest beer.
- Really?
- What? The former Prime Minister?
- Cheers to the Prime Minister
(glasses clinking)
of Australia.
- That's nice.
- That's refreshing.
You know what that is right there?
- The rump?
- The rump...oh....
- Excellent, do you want me to do yours?
- Oh, mine's better dawg.
- How about yours?
- Their both good.
- Mine's just better by default
because its mine.
- Cheers
(upbeat music)
- Mmmmmmm
- That's nice.
- That's amazing that that's just salt,
pepper and bone marrow.
- It's also a steak.
- Right!
- It adds a lot to the flavor.
- It's a little bit meatier, chewier
- It does have that
beefier taste that you get
with the rump, with the roast cuts.
- It's $16
- That's true.
- on a Wednesday night, you got your beer
you got your friends,
what else do you need?
Want some?
- That's really good right?
Adam just said it's really good.
- He just nodded.
- He just nodded, he just went
(nods head)
- It's subtle the ways that he moves.
- I want to know some
good Australian games
I mean we're at a pub, I feel like this
is the appropriate time to pub it up.
- Where do we start?
So there's one where
you obviously get a coin
so you choose heads or tails
whatever it lands you get a
skotlet of beer if you lose.
- $2 coin
- I call it, loser downs it
in the down under.
- Heads
What is it gonna be?
What's it gonna....
- Aw, you lose.
Let the record show
- No!
- That the coin landed tails.
- It was heads, look.
Uh uh.
Uh uh, that's not going down, Adam
can you save me here?
Oh shoot!
Oh!
Maybe he should be the
next Prime Minister?
- That was a tasty steak.
- Was a well done, medium rare steak.
- Oh shit.
- Booya!
Look at that, the crevice.
- You wanna jump it?
(scared laughing)
- I saved your life.
- I hate you.
(yelling)
Steak Fact
(laughing)
Steak Fact - 30 percent of cattle
raised in Australia are grass fed
who spent their entire
life grazing freely.
- That's a good ratio.
- Right?
- I grazed freely, I'm happy.
- Are you a free grazer?
- I'm the Graze Gatsby, Graze Anatomy,
Grazey in Love, Beyonce.
- Oh nice.
(instrumental music)
- Hello my name is Kevin Donovan
I'm the owner of Donovan's Restaurant
along with my wife Gail.
We wanted to create a relaxed,
comfortable environment
on St. Kilda beach.
Actually you know if
Gail changes the interior
accents of the restaurant every six months
she lightens the colors of the restaurant
changes the displays
and people come to the restaurant
every six months and say
"what's new, what did they change"
- Everything is very cozy and I feel
very safe and comfortable here.
- And that is exactly what
we are trying to create.
Emma our chef has been
with us for 15 years
she's gonna show you how we cook our
Tasmanian Wilderness beef T-bone.
- My name is Emma D'Alessandro
and I'm the head chef
at Donovan's Restaurant
here in St Kilda.
Today we are gonna cook the grass fed
British cattle braid T-bone
on the charcoal oven.
So an order will come in
we'll pull it out
brush it with a little bit of oil
season it with salt and pepper
The josper oven I cook it in
sits at about 350 degrees celsius.
Pop it in the oven and
we constantly turn it
until it gets a really nice caramelization
crust on it
and then I'll bring it
out and I'll rest it
so for as long as I've cooked it
I'll rest it for the same amount of time
so when I go to cut it
bloods not gonna ooze
out all over the place.
So you just get this really nice tender
juicy piece of meat.
With that you get housecut chips
with rosemary, salt and fried garlic
a little salad of baby cos leaves
just with a lemon vinaigrette.
It makes a complete meal which
is great when you are paying
that sort of price for a piece of meat.
- To the tazmanian beef.
Alright?
Let's eat.
- Potato cheers?
- Potato cheers.
Mmmmm
- Holy crap
- That is the most potatoey
potato I've ever eaten.
(silverware clanking)
- Do you wanna eat?
- I do.
- Alright let's go, ohhhh
That went right through.
- Cheers
(laughing)
- That awkward moment
when you hold your food
cheers for a little too long.
- This is a great steak.
- Look how even that medium rare is inside
its that bake.
- It's familiar in that it's a steak
but it really tastes like a wild animal.
It's a whole other experience
on the other side of the t.
- Oh, that bone meat,
its so different.
The meat that's right next to the bone
that's what I mean by bone meat
it's like brisket.
- The bone meat
He knows what's up
look at that bone meat right there.
- I'm gonna let Adam have some of mine
because it's not as gnawed on as yours.
Who is a better dinner guest?
- How do you know when
someone enjoys your food?
When they eat like this.
- Yes sir
Donovan's right there
thought we'd come out to the beach
for just a moment.
That steak made me feel things
I've never felt before
gnawing the meat off.
- Like a hyena.
- Yes.
- Like a Tasmanian devil.
- It was.
- Because that was Tasmanian beef.
- Alright here we go.
- So next up
- Is a steak fact!
- One, Two, Three....
(yells)
Steak Fact!
(screaming)
(evil laughter)
- As of June 2017 there
was a bill attempting
to prohibit Australian
cattle that are exported
from being labeled as Australian beef
after they are then
processed in the countries
that import them to be sold.
- Oh, because they are not processing it
good enough.
It doesn't "meat"
their standards.
- So we are on the way to the last
steak place.
It's back in Sydney but before we go
I have a treat for you
I want to go to the farm
where the Wagyu was raised.
- Let's go meet some cows.
(soft music)
- My name is David Blackmore
I'm the founder of Blackmore Wagyu Beef.
This farm is a breeding farm
the cows are born here
and conceived here.
- What is Wagyu beef?
- [David] Wagyu beef is a Japanese
breed of cattle.
A lot of people think it's a process.
The Japanese have got this unbelievable
breed of cattle that
produces unbelievable meat.
How the hell did they do it?
You're talking about very,
very accurate information.
Average daily weight
gain, the marbling score
every animal has a different nose print.
That was how they've
been able to make sure
that there was no cheating
keep accurate records.
I can do this for probably
at least ten generations
on all these cattle that are behind us.
We've got an unbelievable database
with over ten thousand
animals now recorded.
So we can look at that and see which of
our best breeding cows and which are the
best bulls that they breed to.
- What makes a cow delicious?
- To be honest, a lot of love
and I know that might sound really corny
but the main thing that
can affect the quality
of meat is whether the cow
has been under stressed.
So we actually monitor everything from
prior to conception, right
through to the weening
of the calf and then every other stage
right through as well.
You know I like the fact
that we can put flavor
into beef and make it something
really different and special.
- Do what you love right?
- And it is, I do love what I'm doing.
- I gotta say truly this has
been the coolest experience
- Ya, it's been great fun
having you guys here too.
(soft music)
- My name is Corey Costelloe
I'm the head chef here
at Rockpool Bar & Grill
in Sydney, and today you
guys are gonna be having
two of the David Blackmore Wagyu steaks.
We get a lot of whole animals in
and we break them down
into all the different
various cuts but then we
have them all aging up
in a room.
- What is the advantage of dry aging meat?
- The natural moisture that's in the meat
when you dry age it
intensifies that moisture
it's like reducing a stock down
and making it more flavorsome.
The first steak you guys will be eating
will be the Wagyu eye of chuck
really, really big in flavor
and we actually we never
used to serve it as a steak
we used to cut it up and braise it.
All the chefs would come along
and cut off the first cuts of them
and start eating them and
the main chef was like
that's it if this is
good of all of us to eat
it's good enough for the guests.
So a new steak was born.
Our butcher will age them anywhere between
21 up to about 75 days.
And we very, very lightly
sprinkle them with salt
a little bit of oil
and then we cook it
over a wood fire grill.
Crust it up on each side
and then just before
the guests are ready to eat it we give it
a little sear up again and then I slice it
on a board.
Certain steaks have grains
that run through them
and we try to cut them
out so that the guests
gets the best experience.
(clapping)
- That's just for our time in Australia
We saw a cow.
- Sure did.
(glasses clinking)
- Ya, it still gets me
- Still ya
- the first sip of wine always, just.
The current table setting
onion rings and steak is
child Andrew's
(laughing)
perfect table setting.
- To Andrew's world
- Oh my God, wow, it's
just straight up funion
it's crazy.
- It's so good.
- Alright
- We've waited long enough.
So this is the eye of the chuck.
- This is the cut chefs prefer to eat
when they come to Rockpool.
Are you ready to put this in your mouth?
- Who are you talking to?
- You.
- Oh, okay, ya, I am.
- Cheers
(relaxing music)
- Mmmmmmm
- I'm just gonna go right back in.
- Mmmmm, all the best
things in life are done
with your eyes closed.
Sleeping, making out.
- I can't disagree with
that, it's really good.
It takes like a beef stock
turned into bubble gum.
- It's reverse bubble gum.
- It's reverse bubble gum?
- It tastes better the
more you chew into it.
- [Corey] The next one you will
have is a grass fed sirloin
comes from the middle of
the back of the animal.
Very high marbles, beautiful eating
we've got it for $150 on
the menu at the moment.
So, bargain.
- Bargain at $150 dollars.
- Bargain at $150
dollars, comes with lemon.
(laughing)
- Immediately, visually
this one looks crazy
compared to the other.
- Sizzle me with your zest
not literally me.
Look at that marbling.
- And the grain structure is crazy
it's like a comb of meat.
- Cheers, to all of Australia.
(symphony music)
- That has a very intense flavor.
- Oh my God, I'm blind.
Don't worry we won't make out.
- It's so easy to eat I can't slow down
and it's already cut for you
I could demolish one of
these in about 5 minutes
if I was by myself not trying to be
conscious of other people watching me.
- There's only salt and lemon on this guy?
- All of the flavor is baked into the cow.
- I just want to sit here and enjoy this
for the rest of my life.
- Well you can't because
I'm about to eat it all,
I'm ready to go home.
(sings)
- I'm coming home.
- Ya, and with that.
- We're back in the states
and back in the worth it mobile.
- Driving back on the
right side of the road.
- Because its the correct side or
because it's the right side?
- Both
- Alright, so the trip is
over but we must now decide
which steak was the most
worth it to at its price
in Australia.
- The Clovely Hotel had
an amazing value steak
that would be the
perfect post beach steak.
Do you eat post beach steaks?
- Pre-beach
- Pre-beach steaks
The steak that was most worth it to me
at its price was certainly Donovan's.
- I knew you were gonna say that.
- I mean that place is what I would want a
restaurant to look like if I operated it.
Here's what I will say
about this steak video.
Every location was amazing.
- But there must be a winner.
Our winner goes to Rockpool.
- Whoa
- It's not the $150 sirloin
it's the eye of the chuck.
(sings)
- It's the eye of the chuck,
it's the thrill of the steak
- Adam?
Five for five one of you
guys chose the same thing?
We're halfway through the season
and you guys are the same person.
(laughing)
It only gets better from here, so.
- It could get worse.
- That's what you call
a teaser.
- What do you think Australian's call
up here?
Because we call that down under
are we up over?
- Um
- Alright, Australia over.
Uh, oh yes!